we're all facing the same problems we're
overloaded with too much information or
start for time
i have a more complex calendar than most
people that you know most normal people
do i mean executives would see my
calendar go oh yeah i understand that
but what everybody does have is that
feeling of stress
and you have three things to do right
that's stress
my goal is to remove that stress look at
your calendar for the past four weeks
and put into buckets how you spent your
time
and you're going to be shocked at the
way that you spent your time right
that's still one of the biggest
challenges with the email calendar and
all the collaborative tools is how do i
as the individual knowledge worker
decide what i want to do every day
reaching everybody enabling everybody to
be more productive to be more effective
right calendar of the future is
responsible for aggregating data
analyzing and providing me insight into
my life analytics i think is the
near-term thing that everyone
could use and it's not that hard to do
but no one has done it that's right in a
lot of ways it just boils down to what
are you going to manage and how are you
going to prioritize and i think the two
things that are driving a lot of
people's decisions and actually
challenging them today are how do you
manage your information and there's a
lot of information overload and how do
you manage your time when there are too
many demands on your time and you've got
to start making choices actually seeing
the content of my calendar tells me what
is important to me because it reflects
the choices i make in how i spend my
time how i spend my money and who i
spend my time with and it's all about
time and place but at the end of the day
all these different sources need an
anchor and this anchor is your calendar
that's a natural repository where all
this information should be and that you
can capture so that you can better
figure out how to optimize your time it
isn't just necessarily you know schedule
this or schedule that but it's all the
things that are going on in your life
and how you tie in and that's what's
really exciting about this you're going
to be able to
change your
interactions with your community
with people around you because of
calendar at the end of the day time is
one of the most critical ones that you
can't you can't get more right right and
so when it comes down to making a lot of
decisions how you spend the time i think
people who help manage that with an
informed insight about the user's
behavior will have an incredible value
proposition the thing that excites me
the most is analytics on how
i've spent my time
and then maybe goal setting about how i
want to spend my time in the future
and the calendar sort of
sets these goals how do i use the
calendar to more effectively manage my
day as opposed to my day being managed
by the calendar the calendar of the
future optimizes my time and as a result
it optimizes my life
you